Welcome to ¡Fiesta Latina!
For 18 years, the Yale Peabody Museum and
the Junta for Progressive Action have gotten
together to have this marvelous celebration
of Fiesta Latina!, which in 2020 we are
moving to a virtual world, together with the
New Haven Free Public Library, the Yale Latino
Networking Group, and the Yale School for
the Environment.
Fiesta Latina! is a celebration of traditional
and contemporary cultures from Latin America,
and it is a wonderful opportunity to bring
our voices here, whether you are a scientist,
an artist, a leader, whoever you are, all
together during Latinx Heritage Month, to
work and learn to be able to have a more just
and sustainable future.
We'd like to thank AVANGRID, our sponsor,
for the opportunity to have a Fiesta Latina!
this year, and we want to invite all of you
to participate in all the events we have organized.
We look forward to seeing you!